now we have cat and with Craig later to
talk about PR for content PR and content
for growth thanks thank you Jeff hi
everyone I'm cat mini Alec I'm a partner
at Y Combinator and during my time at YC
I've helped hundreds of companies with
their launches with their pitches with
their initial interactions with press
I'm and I'm gonna be joined by Craig
cannon who creates a lot of the content
for YC and we're going to be giving you
a framework for thinking about marketing
content marketing and press as an early
stage founder so Before we jump in let's
define some terms when we talk about
content we're talking about anything
that you create and distribute on your
own channels to attract a specific
audience or user so that means anything
you make for your blog YouTube podcasts
anything that you create and distribute
yourself when when we talk about PR or
press were referring to an early stage
startup pitching an independent
third-party publication so that's news
blogs anything that's external to your
channels so as a founder it's one of
your primary job is to tell the story of
your startup you'll need to tell that
story to investors to press to users to
potential employees and you'll need to
tell that story throughout the entire
lifetime of your company so it's best to
start practicing early so you will need
to tell it clearly and succinctly
because the goal is to tell it in a way
where in other people it makes it easy
for other people to repeat that story
for you and help you spread the word
that's how anything becomes viral so
making good content lets you shape that
story and put it out into the world
yourself and then pitching it to press
helps you put that story in front of a
potentially much larger audience so the
combination of the two can be really
powerful but making good content and
setting up a press practice is a lot of
work so you have to decide and hopefully
I'll help you make that go through that
decision tree whether it's worth doing
at the stage where you're at right now
am
so we will cover we will cover when and
why to start thinking about doing
content marketing how to think about
content like a product and how to
measure it how to DIY your own PR and
then we'll open it up to questions and
so a couple things before we get started
first for the majority of you before you
focus too much time and energy getting
the word out about what you're building
make sure that you're making something
people want make sure you're focusing on
the right things and it all comes back
to this writing code and talking to
users no amount of press or content
marketing is going to help you if you
don't have something people want and how
do you know that you have something
people want you talk to your users and
additionally talking to your users will
make it easier for you to create better
content and do press that will target
them and second press is not a scalable
user acquisition strategy it can help
you get some early inbound it can help
get you in front of early adopters but
it's not something you can rely on long
term for growth it's not something you
can really control and it's not even the
best way to talk to your earliest users
which is why we're gonna talk about
content and content marketing first and
I will let Craig kick it off here hey
everyone I'm Craig I work with cat at YC
do the podcasts and all that kind of
stuff all right so I before working at
YC I worked at a place called the onion
we made fake news before it was cool I
didn't I did a Photoshop so like putting
Joe Biden's head on like fat guys body
in front of the White House that kind of
thing oh and then after working at the
onion I co-founded a company and we made
a thing called comedy hack day where
developers and comedians work together
to make funny apps and then we had these
big events Alexus judged a bunch of them
and now I work at YC
so hopefully that's like the least
logical connection of things in this
deck so today I'm going to talk about
content content marketing some people
call it content marketing some people
call it editorial some other people call
it brand publishing some people call it
social content and then some other
people call it a word I don't know but
like Kat said this is just like
basically everything you make so it's
gonna be like your podcast YouTube blog
video social stuff whatever we can get
like more specific and granular about
each of those channels if you want to
talk one-on-one but this is going to be
kind of like broad across-the-board
advice that hopefully you can use so the
number one question I get is when to
start really the thing is just like Kat
said and just like Gustav said last week
about applying growth tactics you really
want to be doing this after you've made
something people want and you're
confident that they're not churning
because if they're churning you're just
wasting a ton of energy and a ton of
money so assuming you've hit that point
you can start thinking about content
marketing a lot of people do this in the
beginning because they can't afford paid
acquisition so the way I think about it
is the content as product hopefully you
can just apply all the learnings from
the delet the lectures earlier on about
product and just throw them right at
content content so when you think about
content is product the only thing you
have to change from like the YC advice
of makes something people want is make
something your customers want you are no
longer bounded by nothing you have this
very clear market that you're going
after and you want to make something
that they're interested in I was talking
with Wade foster from zapier they do a
ton of content marketing it's really
good and they write about it on their
blog you can check it out
oh sweet all right cool thanks man and
what he was saying is that in the early
days what they were doing was making
things that hacker news wanted but it
turns out that hacker news and their
customers was not a 100%
overlap so they were spending all this
energy generating this content to get
people through the door but those
weren't actually the customers that they
were looking for so just keep that in
mind and so now that you've committed to
doing content marketing you're gonna do
this what you need to do is pick a goal
so there are basically two things that
early-stage companies want engagement if
you're if you're social company that's
like you know Instagram whatever that's
like time on site anyone else it's gonna
be conversions there's this third thing
called brand which is kind of this like
vague misty thing about like how people
perceive you you really don't need to
worry about this early on I mean
obviously you don't want to like do evil
things and have people hate you but it's
much harder to kind of comprehend and
work towards so engagement or
conversions and now that you're going
you want to just set up analytics Suhail
talked about this but really it's like
super basic stuff the first thing I
would do is set up mix panel not Google
Analytics but something similar to mix
panel will get the job done you're just
tracking where people are coming in what
they're doing what they're clicking on
how long they're on their site all that
stuff and then the next thing you want
to do is install a Facebook pixel again
this might not be super valuable to you
in the beginning but a lot of YC
companies launch without a Facebook
pixel and what this is gonna do is
capture who's hitting your site who's
logged into Facebook so then you can
later remark it at them and this is
gonna be much cheaper than any other
kind of Facebook audience that you can
create so you want to do this because if
you launch on Hacker News and have like
10,000 people hit your site and you
don't have it installed you won't know
who it is afterward all right so the
next most common question I get is what
platform this one's actually not that
difficult you just want to find your
customers so you just talk to them be
like where do you hang out do you hang
out on reddit Instagram whatever you can
look at your referred data but this is
really all you have to do because your
objective is to find people like them
and and then once you're hanging out
there long enough you're gonna be able
to figure out what does well they're so
for instance like essays like Paul
Graham's essays they do well in hacker
news makeup tutorials do well on YouTube
vlogging all that kind of stuff because
you're gonna be wanna be you're gonna
want to make the stuff that does well on
those platforms this is for two reasons
distribution is really hard even for
huge companies a lot of companies would
just rely on paid acquisitions you know
like boosted posts on Facebook that kind
of thing and you have no money and so
assuming these two things are true you
have to figure out where your customers
are and you have to figure out what does
well they're two examples so scent bird
they're YC company they do a perfume and
like makeup subscription box they do
Instagram influencer marketing you can
read all about this online they've
blogged about it a bunch
another example is YC so YC although PG
and Jessica Robert and Trevor might not
say this has been doing like content
marketing since the very beginning even
before so with Paul's essays and then
hacker news was built and then those
essays do really well and that's the
exact kind of audience that would create
a startup they just kind of like rinse
and repeat alright so now that you found
out where you're gonna go in like
generally what you want to be making I
think um not enough people spend enough
time brainstorming it sounds kind of
silly but most content because people
don't spend enough time brainstorming
ends up being derivative of all like the
average of all the other stuff people
see so it doesn't stand out and it looks
like all the other stuff because you've
got the ideas from the other people
whose blogs are reading or your
competitors whatever and my example of
this is going back to the onion so the
onions been around for like thirty
thirty years maybe more at this point
and they've had hundreds of people work
there this is how the onion picks
headlines and I think it's particularly
important because it's allowed them to
create
consistently good stuff with a lot of
different people over a long period of
time so the way the onion picks
headlines is they have say 10 10 writers
each writer is responsible for 10 to 15
headlines a week and then they email
those headlines to an editor the editor
removes everyone's name and then they
just pick their favorite as a group and
so the objective is to have like only 5
to 10 percent roughly survive and so
what this is really good at is first of
all it removes biases for like who's the
CEO who's the new guy or whatever or
girl whatever and it also gets you past
the point of the like those first 3
ideas which are kind of the same from
everyone this is like a huge problem and
if you go on like just any average
company blog they're all writing about
the same stuff so it's a huge mistake
I think the onion got it right there's a
This American Life episode about it if
you want to learn more and that's how
you get this this is one of my favorite
ever is before my time but it's so good
oh man all right can we just stay here
for the rest of its no just kidding
all right so now you want to make
something good again this is like dumb
stuff that should be self-evident but I
don't I don't know it doesn't seem to be
based on the internet what does that
mean
so that means dedicating real time so to
break down what I talked about before
maybe that's like an hour a week or
every two weeks brainstorming and then
it could take you a whole day it could
take you two days it could take you
three days to write a blog post and you
know maybe in the early days you can't
do that but you should let that amount
of time dictate how often you can put
stuff out rather than go the other way
and be like [ __ ] I have to get a thing
out every week and then you write a post
in ten minutes and it's garbage and so
you're just wasting your time
you also want to dedicate good people
doesn't have to say that you're hiring
bad people but what it's saying is that
you want to dedicate the people who have
actual domain expertise and can lend
something that's in
wresting to the rest of the world you
know that means usually like a
co-founder lead developer that kind of
thing just two other little things from
the media world you need to be prepared
to edit all the time like just really be
precise about your language because
people don't spend that much time on
your site or your video or whatever and
you need to be prepared to kill a lot of
your work and that really sucks but you
have to do it you know like I said at
the onion like most headlines by
definition would not make it through I
think for a company that's really hard
to do but you know you can easily kill
25% of your stuff and so this is I want
to illustrate why this is important most
people think that they're competing with
people that make the same stuff that
they make that is 100% not true you are
competing with this Elon Musk smoking
weed on Joe Rogan's podcast I haven't
checked the views but I think it's
probably like 10 million now and this is
like a 2 or 3 hour podcast this is the
internet you're competing with this guy
you're competing with porn you're
competing with everything else on the
internet and once you like really let
that sink into your brain you will have
the motivation to make something that's
both valuable and engaging man that was
a good podcast - all right so then the
next thing this is the part that's
really hard for me is promotion so
promotion is both incredibly boring and
totally necessary this means like
sharing articles out over and over on
your Twitter feed figuring out new
different creative ways to do it a lot
of people will tell you to make a
version for each platform you can do
this but again you're gonna be
optimizing for one place where your
customers are you know YC it's so like
now like I clip up the podcasts and like
put it on Instagram and that's cool but
like we're still getting way more
podcast downloads than we are getting
like Instagram views and that's just how
it goes
not everything's gonna work everywhere
I'm putting this slide in here twice
because if I were watching this talk
this would be the thing that I'd be like
oh yeah man I got it don't worry about
it and then I would skip over it and
then I would have played myself because
I'm dumb and lazy and I would not
promote it enough and ice-t is awesome
all right so just really quickly I'm
gonna rip through a couple examples so
Gustav talk talked about this one last
week
SEO Airbnb you made a bunch of CD guides
so these are both super useful they get
you on the site you can hit someone with
a face Facebook pixel you can get your
brand in there and then you can convert
like this is such a dream for them
influencer sent bird influencer
marketing if you google just those two
words you'll read a bunch of blog post
about that customer profiles so zapier
who I mentioned earlier they help
non-technical people work with api's by
doing all these integrations for them
what's particularly cool about this is
that they are always finding new and
creative ways to link stuff together the
customers want to talk about themselves
and they do it over text text interviews
are like a total cheat code for young
companies because they require way less
production than video or audio the
internet really likes it for like SEO
for scraping and it makes the person
look really smart we've done some of
these at YC you time over time like the
person wants to promote it more than
they do then when they see themselves in
a video and they feel weird so that's an
easy thing to do industry advice is
another great one so triple bite helps
companies hire engineers intercom is
that little like chat widget you've
probably seen before
desk trainer at intercom writes about
product and content marketing those are
great essays triple bite hard who used
to be at YC writes about hiring
engineers these are all great posts with
the one caveat being that you have to
really know what you're talking about or
this just won't ring true
next thing tools front this is a YC
company they made a website called good
email copy or something like that or
Matilda just like pulled together her
favorite lines from emails and then
tagged things so like onboarding we're
shutting the company down like all kinds
of like fairly templated emails and you
can go on there and check them all out
so if you have like extra engineering
time these can be super effective
community so both hacker news and
product hunt we're kind of like built
out from from YC entities but just
getting good at engaging with your
community on HN in product ton is really
undervalued if you're someone who's like
known as like a good actor on these
sites and like engages with people and
is cool that's worth your time not
saying just like lurk and comment on
everything but you just know how it
works if that's where your customers are
and then the last thing and this is like
not exhaustive at all but these are just
like some examples publishing so stripe
is now making books 37signals Basecamp
they make books too this is super
powerful in terms of like your
influencer status but really really hard
to track so this would be later down
later down the road but it is effective
and because it's hard most people aren't
going to do it so you can really stand
out and that's it so cats going to come
up to talk about press
[Applause]
all right so let's jump back into press
so why as I mentioned it's not a
scalable user acquisition but it can get
you some early adopting users it can
give you you know your investors or
potential employees a heads up that you
exist and it can help with SEO so a lot
of people ask when do when should I
start to thinking about press so ideally
you will have a sense that you're making
something people want as we said so for
most startups it's worth waiting to
pitch until there's a call to action for
your intended audience so is there a
product that they can try or buy or
something they can sign up for so most
companies who go through YC wait until
they have a launched product and some
very early users before they bother
pitching to press there are some
exceptions so there are companies that
do press pre product if there's
something particularly novel about the
or notable about the company this is
especially true if you're working on a
bio company or something in the hard
sciences that will take you a long time
before you get to product and there are
other companies that wait years before
they do press and so one thing to note
is that most media outlets don't cover
very early stage startups anymore so you
shouldn't waste their time with a
non-story um think about what you're
pitching objectively why should they
care about this and why now and so you
know that's one reason why a lot of
startups will the first time they pitch
press will be to announce a fundraising
round because that's timely news and
that's why you see a lot of those
fundraising announcements it's just an
opportunity a timely opportunity to
pitch so so we'll talk about I'll go
through a checklist of things that you
should prepare when you are pitching
press and the mechanics of how to do it
but a first a quick word on PR firms
don't hire them at the stage that you're
at PR firms are way too expensive
typically you have to keep them on a
monthly retainer
and you know most companies even through
seed series a they don't have the budget
for that so the thing is that your
relationships that you build now would
press will hopefully similar to
investors last throughout the entire
lifecycle of your company so you want to
do that work early you shouldn't bother
thinking about hiring a firm or someone
in-house until you have more funding and
so much inbound that the founders can't
deal with it themselves and so one thing
that you know PR people so so PR people
you know a lot of people think oh if I
hire someone to do PR they'll magically
think of all the most interesting
stories that I can pitch well that's not
the case the most interesting stories
are going to come from you the founders
you know your company better than anyone
else
and so what PR firms do have is
connections to reporters but you can
build those yourself and here's how we
think about it we treat PR like business
development
so like BD or sales which you wouldn't
outsource early in your company's life
you shouldn't outsource pitching to
press in the very early stages of your
company as I said like these are
relationships that you should build now
and we'll hopefully have for years to
come
and so when you think about you know how
to do this we can talk about what you
need to do to DIY your own PR
essentially so we will walk through that
now so um a couple things that I
recommend any company do is and people
ask me how much time should I be
spending on this so here's some
recommended prep work I think you can
spend at least thirty minutes per week
reading about the news in your industry
keep a list of publications that cover
your space a list of media outlets that
your users read and a list of specific
reporters are interested in your
vertical so if you don't know which
outlets to track or to read talk to your
users and ask them what they read and
what they're interested in then I think
that if you decide you want to try
pitching to press I think about it in
three to six
increments of time so you can build a
calendar you can spend half an hour once
a month thinking about what milestones
are coming up that you're gonna hit what
announcements you might have and map
them out so here's an example using a
startup school company in this batch
they're called or B or B is building
flying robots that help retail with
inventory tracking and surveillance so
for example in January assuming you know
they raise a seed fund they might want
to announce their seed fund rated C seed
fundraising with the you know intended
audience of being engineers then in
March for example they may want to pitch
a trend data story a retinue targeted at
CTOs
that talks about how AI is lifting up
brick-and-mortar retail sales so you
know it's just good to kind of do these
brainstorming exercises similar to what
Craig talked about in the content space
for potential stories that you can pitch
externally to press so once you've
decided you want a pitch a story and the
first thing to do is to define your
goals and your audience that will help
you determine everything else who you
want to pitch you know this exact story
you want to pitch and how to measure its
success and so once you know who your
audience is you have to draft three
things a one-sentence pitch a three to
five sentence pitch and answers to
frequently asked questions so questions
that are frequently asked by reporters
to early stage startups so let's dig
into each one of these things so one
sentence pitch should go over two things
what you're building and who you're
building it for and you should be able
to say this in jargon free terms that
anyone can understand and repeat so here
are a couple examples of startup school
companies who I think had pretty strong
one-sentence pitches coming in so or be
who I mentioned before
flying robots that help businesses
monitor inventory and do surveillance
it's so clear and straightforward that I
remembered it you know just off the top
of my head when I was describing them
earlier you want anyone to be able to do
that for your company the second one is
another startup school company the box
company they're building smart
eco-friendly box
says for food delivery so you know what
they're building and who they're
building it for for both of these
examples and for probably all of your
companies a one-sentence pitch isn't
going to capture everything that you're
doing but you don't have to communicate
that in the one sentence pitch just make
it really clear and compelling enough
that people follow up with with
questions and you know you want them to
ask you you know questions that will let
you give them more context so next is
the three sentence pitch with a three to
five sentence pitch you can give us that
that context you can give us more of the
story you should talk not only about
what your company does and who the
customer is but why it's better than
what's currently in the market and then
also if there's anything really notable
that the founders or the story or the
market make sure to put that in there so
usually when we are pitching companies
at YC when we are pitching to press
about their launches or fundraising this
is the pitch that we send to reporters
so let's go through two examples for or
B and the Box company so or B is
building flying robots that help
businesses monitor inventory and do
surveillance the robots were designed
with safety in mind and are outfitted
with light weight vision sensors that
let them navigate autonomously alongside
retail or warehouse employees or we can
save employees hours of manual will work
per shift so they can spend more time
doing things that matter like serving
and helping customers the company is
currently in pilot talks with major US
retailers so we covered what they do you
know who they're building it for and why
they're better than what's currently in
the market when I talk to the or B
founders they said you know what makes
us special is that these are very
lightweight and they're very safe so
that they can fly around indoors
you know alongside humans and really
help them you know we also tease the
fact that they are in talks with big
retailers and so that's something that
might pique someone's interest a
reporter's interest second is the box
company they're building smart
eco-friendly boxes for food delivery and
then you can talk a little bit about the
market the food delivery market is on
the rise
it's predicted to grow 79% by 2020 and
then you can talk about the problem but
it's still difficult to order food to
order delivery and get the same quality
would get in a restaurant
additionally packaging is often non
recyclable and non compostable which
creates an enormous waste problem so
then you talk about their solution the
box company is solving these issues with
a patented box that improves the entire
delivery process and you could talk a
little bit about the units that they're
stackable easy to assemble they solve
this soggy sloppy food problem and you
know then if you have specific you know
if so say they have a customer they want
to might want to put that in talk a
little bit about their progress but here
again you have a little bit more context
you can show how big of a problem it is
and how they're solving it so now you
have this I think it's best to for you
and your co-founders to draft the
answers to frequently asked questions
that reporters ask so I talked to many
reporters and one of them sent me this
list and while she was at Laura kolodny
while she was at the Wall Street Journal
she said these are the questions that I
asked all earliest age startups and
expect them to know how to answer and so
you know I won't go through every single
one of these now but you can take a
photo of it or reference it later but
these are so it's best to draft really
succinct answers to these and one piece
of advice I have is that it's great to
practice it's great to practice your
succinct answers but I wouldn't over a
hearse because you don't want to sound
like a marketing robot with everything
memorized you don't wanna have these
memorize answers that you use in every
context so what I typically tell
founders to do is have answers to all
those questions and then what I
recommend doing before talking to press
is bullet pointing the three to five
points that you want to make sure to
talk about in an interview and then let
the rest of the answers to questions
sort of flow organically so it's good to
practice but don't over rehearse so
let's talk now about how to pitch to
press like
what the mechanics are now that you've
done this prep work now that you're
ready I will dig into each one of these
so picking your moment the big question
is why now you know TechCrunch back when
they first started covered pretty much
every single company that launched
because they were like you know one
startup every two weeks would launch and
in the early 2000s but now they get tens
if not hundreds of pitches per day so
you have to think about you know what's
your news hook like you know if you have
news like a fundraising round that sort
of makes it easy or if you can show that
you're part of a trend or current news
story that might be you know what makes
it easier for you to get a response I'm
so the example for or B they can say you
know or B we're a flying robot company
and we're giving brick and mortar
retails a fighting chance against Amazon
so everyone's talking about you know
it's all retail against Amazon these
days so if you can plug yourself into a
trend piece like that that make it makes
it easier so another thing to think
about around timing is that if there's a
big news event happening that week don't
pitch your story so if you're you know
reaching out to TechCrunch during
TechCrunch Disrupt
you'd be crazy lucky to get a response
from them or if you're pitching a
reporter who covers Apple don't hit them
up during WWDC like your chances of
getting a response to decrease immensely
and so now after you are picking your
moment you have your news hook you know
what you want to pitch you can pitch
your target target and this is easy
because you think through who is your
audience what are my goals think about
what they read
I would stack rank a list of your top
three choices so have you know these are
the three publications that I would most
like to cover my news and be realistic
realistically the New York Times isn't
going to cover a newly-born company and
as much as I would love them to and so I
would you know look at who is actually
covering startups at your stage and in
your vertical and add those as your you
know your first three choices and so
then
basically I would recommend giving an
exclusive to your first choice so an
exclusive is one you pitch your story to
just one reporter and if they agree to
pick it up you don't give anyone else a
briefing or a heads up until that
reporter you know publishes their story
and a lot of people ask why an exclusive
versus giving you know kind of a lot of
different reporters a heads up on the
news so the reason is a reporter is more
likely to pick up your story and write
it if they get an exclusive if they can
break the break the news if they can get
that scoop
so I recommend offering that one
publication at exclusive and once you're
a bigger company and more of a household
name or your bigger you know say
fundraising Series A plus news or huge
hires then you can think more about
briefing multiple reporters at once but
early stage for the vast majority of YC
companies in any one pre YC I always
recommend exclusives first and so now
that you know you know who your target
is that you want to offer them an
exclusive how do you get in touch with
that reporter and so the best way to get
in touch with reporters is through warm
introductions just like business
development right the best way to get an
answer from someone is to get a personal
introduction to that person to that
reporter and so cold emailing will get
you maybe if you're lucky a one in ten
response and warm introductions will get
you know at least half the time you'll
get someone to respond to you so you
know what I would do is create that
stack rank list here are the top three
you know choices of reporters you'd want
to reach out to if I were or B for
example I might want to hit up Laura
kolodny at CNBC she covers drones and
flying industrial robots and so you know
she I would then ask my network you know
everyone I know on Facebook any other
founders I know would you be willing to
get does anyone know laura has she
covered anyone in my network and would
you be willing to give me a warm
introduction and so YC founders often
ask each other for introductions to
press and so that's for them the easiest
way and often and so assuming you find
that person to give you an intro
make it as easy as possible for them to
introduce you so I would draft the email
for them you this is what a draft email
might look like they should be no longer
than this anything longer than you know
two short paragraphs a reporter or
anyone really their eyes will glaze over
so I'm draft that warm in you know intro
email for your friend and and you know
hopefully you have a better chance of
getting a response from that reporter
and then finally I would say give it
time I often get requests from founders
saying like oh can you help me out I
need this to be done tomorrow I want to
launch on Wednesday and that just isn't
going to happen so ideally you know work
your way back say you want to announce
something two or three weeks from now
give it at the very least two weeks for
the whole process of warm introductions
and making you know a you know meeting
with that reporter and then having the
piece come out so two weeks is the
absolute minimum time I would give it
and then sort of you know what things
you know what not to do once you're in
touch for the reporter and some of these
sound pretty obvious and I I don't
believe any of you would ever do these
things one is don't lie don't fudge your
numbers don't say you can do things that
you can't you know as we've seen some
you know very public instances in the
press of things like that happening
those stories will always come back and
haunt you I've seen it time and again ii
don't have like you're entitled to a
story so if you get in touch with
reporter feel free to you know follow up
if they kind of go silent follow up once
or twice very politely but don't sort of
you know I've seen some founders you
follow up every single day for weeks and
it just that's crazy
don't do that because then that reporter
will write you off and you won't have
that relationship long term don't
suggest headlines or copy this is the
reporter's job to do and you know they
see it can they can be a I've seen
people get offended by founders
suggesting specific headlines and then
don't ask to see a draft
I've we've worked with a lot of folks
that come from the life sciences and bio
and they're surprised by this one
they're used to peer-reviewed journals
and but the thing is reporters get
incredibly offended they think you're
questioning their journalistic integrity
if you ask to see what they're writing
before they publish it so don't ask to
see a draft I mean there are certain
cases where sometimes they need to
fact-check some things so they'll show
you something ahead of time but let them
make that ask of you and as I mentioned
don't speak like a marketing robot just
you know talk like a human know know
your numbers know the answers to the
questions but don't worry about having
everything super memorized and so if
everything goes well and you know you
have a piece that is published as Craig
says don't be lazy take the time to
promote it you have you know social
media channels promoted on all your own
channels and if you have an email list
of investors or friends you know shoot
them a note saying hey good news we were
in TechCrunch and you I would draft a
tweet for them and when folks trim you
know draft tweets for me to send out and
much more likely to just copy and paste
and you know help them promote it so
promote the story you know don't be
afraid to ask friends and family put it
on all the socials and then Plan B if
they you know if it turns out no one
wants to run your story it's not a big
deal it's not gonna make or break you so
post it on your own channels and put it
through the whole content process you
know I think it's it's a reasonably good
practice to do that and then think about
after you go through this whole process
was it worth it did it help did the
piece that came out in TechCrunch or
Wall Street Journal or Bloomberg
actually help you achieve the goal that
you set for it did you get new users on
your platform did you get potential
investors you know inbound and did it
actually help you achieve what you said
it what you set out to achieve and so
that is the entire process and we'll
just open it up to Q&A if anyone has any
questions Craig you want to come back up
here
all right if journalists are already
reaching you and you don't find market
they'd never be focus on product at the
moment it should each spend any time in
meeting with them or to just like focus
on the cockpit so the question if if
journalists are proactively reaching out
to you and are interested in writing
about you but you don't have to really
early and don't have product market fit
what can you like should you spend any
time engaging them you know frankly I
you know it can you know it does helped
us have that relationship and if there's
a way you can be helpful you're like
reasonably quickly or like oh you have a
question about this you know vertical or
this industry I'm happy to answer but I
wouldn't then spend a huge amount of
time pitching your story but you say
like I'd love to keep you posted on our
progress and then check in with them
regular regularly or when you have news
but I think it is good to be helpful
early on what are you gonna write about
oh right yeah sorry if you are just
starting out in content marketing you're
debating whether to do a personal blog
or a company blog my question to you
would be are you writing just about
company stuff okay so one thing that's
really effective is doing it like title
of blog by so-and-so
like you see this with a lot of podcasts
it's like whatever the podcast name I
mean like Joe Rogan is like a good
example but that's not a company thing
people connect with other humans and so
you like having that little extra touch
is nice but I would say overall like
you're gonna want it on your own site
for SEO yeah I like I kind of disagree
with people putting stuff on medium and
so early on yeah I've seen it works
really well when you have like a company
blogging stripe has their company blog
but then they have specific authors for
each blog post but and people really
like connecting with that human
how do you feel about working with
influencers who don't necessarily or
don't have a need for your product at
the top like our company is based around
moving so like if influencer is not
currently moving how do you feel about
working with them it's a promotion the
question is how do you feel about
working with influencers who don't need
your product at the time I I haven't
seen cases like that that have worked
out really well especially for earliest
agent I think a big problem is that
influencers often charge you and are
expensive like if you get some huge
influencer who just loves what you're
doing and wants to tweet about you and
that's great but but more often than not
they're gonna charge you and it's not
worth the conversions not going to be
worth it especially if they're just you
know generally talking about you versus
answering a real need for themselves but
but this is totally something you can
test I like but kind of like what Katz
saying like I wouldn't bet the farm on
something like this be like oh man for
$100,000 we can get in on this thing
like I would skip that but I mean like
at scale it ends up working like I heard
Casey Neistat this vlogger is
responsible for an insane amount of
boosted board sales and I'm pretty sure
they don't pay him anything so it does
work I've seen folks I'm often you know
if you know folks with hardware or like
physical product will send you know
samples or demo pieces to press or
influencers and that's sometimes enough
like Casey nice that loves boosted
boards so he sort of organically talks
about it and that's great but but having
to pay those influencers is not usually
worth it early on
[Music]
with the three to five centons examples
that you for me and company how much it
that is what they're actually doing
today versus what they want to be
growing pork like so we're not buzzing
how do you draw that balance so the
question is with the three to five
sentence example how much of it is
vision for the future and what they you
know hope to do and versus what they're
doing today and so I think it's I think
you can sort of there is a fine line as
you said I think it's possible to
communicate both you know you can say
this is the vision you know and today
they're doing X and so you know four or
be in or B's case I think they have
prototypes they have pieces that you
know can do that theoretically but like
they or at this point when they would be
pitching but you know they can say they
could add a line in there about if there
is a bigger vision for the company that
they hope to achieve you can definitely
drop it in there but I think it's best
for people to know where you're at right
now
um this is on some Greg I think the
clickbait versus authenticity I'm one so
that example of Elon Musk's is great
because they're my mercy on my smoked
weed but there was really awesome stuff
in their podcast and I was authentic but
how do you we've got a lot of great
content but it's really sort of expert
level and we sort of at that level of
what do we want to do some catchy titles
cuz that's gonna bring in the audience
what's your view on this hash we balance
this yeah because you can't give the
audience II do not have some sort of
headline right so I would say so the
question is like make clickbait you the
assumption is like we have a good
content we're not getting a lot of
traffic we're debating whether like to
title it something straight or give it
some clickbait headline hopefully get
people in right right so I'm generally
not for that the thing that bothers me
more than clickbait headlines are really
shitty stock photos like I think that
that's like a red flag more than
anything on a blog so definitely skip
those this is something you can test but
kind of back to that zapier point like
if you know where your customers are and
like know what they really want you
should be able to title it in a way that
will get them to respond if you're going
for like giant mass appeal you might
have to do that but like I've never I've
never had success doing like clickbait
stuff and in getting like good results
yeah I mean depends on what the product
is that's the objective right like it's
not it's not quick made technically yeah
the question is like should you make a
good headliner shitty headline you
should make a good headline
[Music]
during the product marketing the early
stage open to the father's publish
content every how often should public
founders publish content during the
phase we are trying to hit product
market fit still before our product
market fit that's tough I mean as you
were saying that it does take time to
create good content so I don't want to
say you should do something every week
because then that's putting you know
that might be unrealistic for a team of
two right but I mean I would say like if
you can make something actually good
every month you're doing great and I
mean I think a lot of it takes companies
a good amount of time to really find
product market fit so you can start
earlier than you know prior to hitting a
product market fit it's uh it's all
relative to also like the amount of
value that you give with the piece so
like a lot of these like decks like the
mary meeker deck that happens once a
year and then tons of people like
millions of people will download this
thing but if you're gonna like just
right you know a four paragraph blog
post you probably have to publish a
little bit more frequently you know I
mean
[Music]
you don't have right oh yeah so if you
don't have product market fit she did
not write anything I mean it can be
helpful to build your own brand but I
think yeah in general like like I said
in the talk you're just funneling
traffic so the question is if you have a
celebrity that's really gung-ho about
your product and wants to boost and talk
about it what are the potential
downsides Oh like you know like if the
alt right or something decides in what
you know that's happen right so it's
like I mean there are definite downsides
I don't think that it's not something I
would worry too much about I think the
vast majority of companies don't have
this problem I mean it's it's sort of
like but yeah I think he's in general
it's a good problem if you if you have
like people were so excited about what
you're building I mean if in the case of
I think it was New Balance or something
where you know the alt-right was like we
love New Balance you know New Balance
had to come out and say you know you
know we don't endorse you know what when
what they're saying and so I think you
know you have but but this is such an
uncommon problem that that I don't think
you have to worry about it early on and
also like I agree 100% with cat but if
you're getting a celebrity on board just
because they are inflammatory like if
you thought Alex Jones was like the best
representation of your brand and like
you weren't prepared for the [ __ ] show
that was gonna come like that's kind of
on you you know
[Music]
series of obsessor just curious I mean
how often should we send updates or
should we send updates technically um
you know for the vast majority no once
sorry oh yes repeating the question
should be how often should you send
updates to reporters about your product
and the progress that you're making so I
would say that they don't generally want
to hear every you know update you have
about your product or you know that kind
of progress if you have news they
certainly want to hear that if there's
something you want announced and even
you know I would give them the chance to
say no that they're not interested it's
it's worth it if you have news reaching
out there are some cases you know that
where you know for example why see at
this point because we've been around a
while you know a lot of reporters ask to
be added to our email list or a press
list and in in those cases you know you
can send out you can send things out
more regularly but I wouldn't sort of
blast reporters every month with with
your company updates let me give you let
me give this to you
hi so what I've learned over the years
is one journalist live on Twitter so
that's the perfect place I mean if
you're building your product you should
look at which journalists which
publication you want to cover you later
and Twitter is the right place for you
to engage with them and you know they're
super responsive it works amazingly well
apart from that there's this tool called
Herald which is helper reporter it's
just that's where journalists send out
if they're writing a story and they need
help and it could be anything from
biotech to
scene learning to healthcare to anything
and they send out these um emails about
you know what they're looking for so if
that's your passion if you're an expert
in any of any of those things you can
just you don't have to pitch your
product you can just say okay you know
I'm an expert in XYZ this is what I
think about this topic and that reporter
is going to be grateful and you can
build relationships like that so it's
good advice all right thank you thank
you so much and if you have any
questions for us we're just cat k8ttie
at Y Combinator and Craig CRA AIG
Rebecca we're reading this on a video
right now Craig Ojai Combinator com
[Applause]
you